fourth
a super exciting possibility for those
of us who were once gamers
or still are gamers is uh
by creating an immersive gaming
experience so
bcis might be able to once again read
the brain and stimulate parts of the
brain that
enrich in some way the the gaming
experience
this could be very shallow kind of basic
enrichment just being able to measure
levels of excitement emotion
those kinds of things that can aid in
the experience of the game
but also again as i said with augmented
reality
being able to stimulate the visual
cortex in order
to create an immersive visual experience
so with a brain computer interface
beyond just gaming you can
start to think about creating virtual
worlds virtual reality
that's very useful for games but just
creating an immersive experience of all
different kinds
again this is an open question but there
could be
technical barriers in creating an
immersive rich
high bandwidth experience with a virtual
reality headset
versus a brain computer interface it's
an open question
of creating a fully immersive experience
what is easier to do in the long sort of
arc of history
with the technology we have today it
seems clearly more doable in the short
term
to create virtual reality experiences
with a headset
as opposed to something that requires
brain surgery but that's not to say if
we look at the
long arc of technological progress that
the much easier solution will come
from the direct access to the brain
through something like a brain computer
interface
and again i think bigger than gaming a
lot of people write to me about
psychedelics for example which i've
never done
but this would be an example of
something where you can create
visual experiences that are
safe and controlled and can take you
perhaps to some of those different
multiple dimensions
or wherever the heck you go when you
take psychedelics
in a more controlled way perhaps
and maybe even taking a step back into
more kind of vanilla experiences of
visualizations and meditation
so imagine the closed loop
of being able to write and read from the
brain
and aiding the meditation experience
sort of emptying your brain from
thoughts figuratively and
literally
you